seuls les discothèques aujourd'hui d'en
utiliser ça a commencé le vendredi donc
la capacité alors discothèque on
s'adresse à un public particulier
certainement un peu plus jeune est à la
fois plus rebelle et plus docile parce
que il ya tellement longtemps qu'ils
voulaient sortir en boîte qu'ils ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts
je suis pas sûr pour le repas de midi ce
soit facile avec nos clients
même si même si mon avis n'est pas de
dire qu'il ne le faut pas mon ailier
dire que aujourd'hui l'état nous
confiera pas une nouvelle fois ne l'a
pas les moyens et nous n'avons pas les
moyens d'être confiné nouvelles on à la
seule profession du travail des gens qui
n'ont pas de match ce qui nous
positionne à la tête quand ils ne vous
donnent la commande pour peu que le
serveur il est le nez à l'air et lampes
al masri sûr mais je pense que nous
professionnels sont exposées de façon
exponentielle de l'offre si on continue
ce pourrait être confiné mais qui déjà
dit éco et qui des colonies foxtrot donc
viard aucune raison qu'ils aient pas de
par la saisonnalité nord-sud du monde à
nouveau variant échos ouais encore un
nouveau variant est encore plus virulent
foxtrot
donc si la seule solution aujourd'hui
c'est la vaccination et si la seule
solution aujourd'hui c'est d'être ont
pas de confirmer c'est de devoir
vérifier si les gens ont eu soit un test
soit être sanctionné eh bien je pense
qu'on sera obligé de passer par les
fourches caudines
et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est dans
la survie de nos entreprises et qui
risque de voir des automnes et des
printemps à venir très difficile
encore plus sidérant conflit je ne crois
pas que pas sanitaires et soit à date la
solution pour que le virus circule ces
vaccins à la solution dire à la moitié
de la population française parce que
haddad nous sommes la france à
l'actionner 50% la population ça veut
dire que demain économiquement je parle
uniquement pour l'instant et on verra le
côté économiquement
un français sur deux ne pourront plus
faire vivre les commerces maintenant
qu'on sait que le virus est dangereux et
que le vaccin est un remède efficace
contre le virus
mais à plus de raison que dans quelques
mois la solidarité s'applique pour
celles et ceux qui seraient atteintes de
la kobe tu es bien moi je propose par
exemple de passer de trois jours de
carence
lorsqu'une personne est atteint de
lakovic parce qu'il a fait le choix de
passer en rexie des ces fonds soient si
son libre choix à quinze jours c'est que
pendant ces quinze jours il serait pas
ici à payer tout simplement celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas envie de se faire
vacciner
s'ils veulent pas aller à l'hôtel chez
mon ami laurent à lyon ou dans mes
établissements
ils peuvent très bien et librement sans
pas sanitaires se recevoir chez eux à la
maison dans des gîtes louer des choses
sur airbnb ou je ne sais quelle autre
bateau mais sur sur une jambe de bois ou
soyons efficaces soyons pragmatiques
est ce que réellement le pass annie
terre va lutter contre la propagation du
virus
à l'évidence non et puis les quelques
exemples que je vais vous donner est ce
que il faut lutter efficacement et
potentiellement dire à toutes celles et
ceux qui demain feront le choix de ne
pas se faire vacciner de ne pas de
continuer à s'exposer et bien six mois
continuent à s'exposer s'exposeront avec
jean portefeuille pas avec celui de la
solidarité nationale
[Musique]
je considère que le bail sanitaires et
je suis sûr que laurent partage ce point
de vue que le pass à lithaire l'absence
de tourisme est une restriction pour
nous enfin ces deux éléments sion des
restrictions pour nos entreprises pour
la vitalité de nos entreprises je le
disais tout à l'heure
50 % de clients en moins c'est
insoutenable pour pour nos entreprises
donc ce que l'on espère demain c'est du
bon sens c'est de la prise de conscience
à la fois des français et des françaises
dans un discours ford
la président de la république tient la
barque qui tient le pays qui regarde ce
qui se passe son plan européen qui
regarde ce qui se passe au plan
international et qu'il fasse des
propositions
parce que au fond dirigeant d'entreprise
c'est diriger c'est prévoir et bien
demain on espère que le président luca
président et donc prévoir
j'espère qu'il aura un discours
suffisamment mesuré posée et puis en
même temps responsable concernant celles
et ceux qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner mais espoir c'est que on est la
première destination touristique au
monde tout le monde a oublié peut-être
aujourd'hui si le message fort du
président d'un rubis c'est dire je
demande à ce que tous les personnels des
hôtels cafés restaurants soient vaccinés
prix enterrement et que ce soit une
obligation
quel message en envoie au reste du monde
on va recevoir
on va en mourir notre secteur
aujourd'hui sinon on dit tout le
personnel de l'hôtellerie restauration
en france est vaccinée pour la sécurité
de ses clients
c'est bien plus fort veulent pas
s'arrêter a certainement par contre on
faire vacciner les gens qui voudront
sortir en france se passe sanitaire
d'être une menace de nos acheteurs
publics
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de
le mettre en place très sincèrement